our main story tonight concerns earth
it's basically the oscar isaac of
planets in that it seems to be getting
alarmingly hotter every year
it's pretty clear this planet is not
doing great the level of carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere is now higher than
ever in human history and a recent u.n
commission climate report was called an
atlas of human suffering which
coincidentally is also the slogan for
craigslist
luckily though one group is here to fix
it giant corporations many are now
claiming that they've hit upon a
solution becoming carbon neutral or net
zero basically running their businesses
in such a way that they don't increase
the amount of carbon in the atmosphere
as of last year one in five of the
world's 2000 largest publicly listed
companies have now committed to a net
zero emissions target which sounds great
you might even have seen them bragging
about their claims in ads like this one
from united airlines this one from apple
this one from shell and this one from an
unexpected source kitkat is committing
to becoming carbon neutral by 2025
reducing emissions by 50 percent through
forest regeneration
planting 5 million shade trees
supporting regenerative farming and
securing 100 renewable electricity for
our factories worldwide and will offset
any remaining carbon by investing in
climate projects let's give the planet a
break
yeah even kitkat is getting involved
which is a strange sales technique it's
not like you decide to eat a kitkat bar
because of their net zero targets you
decide to eat one because you're at rock
bottom and you've run out of reese's
peanut butter cups that's why you do it
now as for the shovel made out of a
kitkat that seemed less like a
sustainable farming tool and more like
what you'd use to bury the body of the
red m m
but the key phrasing comes at the end
there that they'd offset any remaining
carbon that's actually a common tactic
in fact one study that looked closely at
the net zero promises of dozens of
companies in heavily polluting
industries found that two-thirds of them
are relying on offsets instead of
emissions reductions offsets are wildly
popular even bands have promised over
the years to use them to reduce the
environmental impact of their tours all
the greats have done this dave matthews
bon jovi coldplay and even sergeant
pepper's angsty victorian ghost club
band my chemical romance
a big tour like this uses lots of energy
trucks vans lights sound and more and
that has an impact on the environment so
we've partnered up with a really cool
non-profit organization called reverb to
help us green things up one of the
things that they do is figure out how
much energy the tour uses then they
invest in alternative energy projects to
help make up for it cool
thanks guys and i admit it is nice to
see them represent their core fan base
middle schoolers who have to give a
presentation in front of the class
against their will but
i don't particularly care for the phrase
green things up there it sounds like
something shrek would say right before
he reaches a sexual climax look out i'm
about to green things up watch me donkey
i want you to watch me look me in the
eyes
and yet if the idea that you can simply
invest a little money and make your
carbon footprint disappear sounds too
good to be true that's because it
absolutely is study after study has
indicated that most offsets available on
the market don't reliably reduce
emissions and yet
offsets are now the backbone of the
environmental policies of many of the
biggest polluters on the planet so given
that tonight let's talk about carbon
offsets what they are what they claim to
do and how they may actually be making
things even worse and let's start with
some basic definitions the idea of a
carbon offset is that if you emit co2
into the atmosphere you can offset it by
say planting or protecting trees which
remove carbon from the air or building a
wind farm to replace a fossil fuel plant
here is how bp a major polluter of
course sells the whole idea
i've been driving around and generating
three tons of carbon dioxide which of
course i've released into the atmosphere
to join all the rest of the greenhouse
gases that are already up there
now
imagine
that miles away maybe on the other side
of the world somebody else takes three
tons of carbon dioxide out of the
atmosphere
so what's happened three tons in
three tons out
results zero
now that violently british man did a
pretty good job of illustrating the
concept there i'm not sure he needed to
use the decorations from a clown's
funeral to do it but i guess without
them i'd never have known what it looks
like when you add three to something but
then take three away it simply can't be
done
but if that simple explanation did not
do it for you here is one idiot
explaining offsets to another idiot
using the worst possible metaphor given
who that second idiot is
of course you can buy carbon offsets
which is the equivalent of buying you
know a diamond watch ring and necklace
if you're unfaithful to your wife and
say oh it's just an offset honey no
problem that's right that'll work
what your carbon offset is oh i can sin
all i want i can put out all the
emissions i want but you got to get rid
of your caravan and drive a bicycle
okay set aside hannity's inability to
decide if he thinks carbon offsets are
like buying your wife a necklace or
forcing someone else to ride a bike
let's just dwell on him saying the words
if you're unfaithful to your wife to
newt gingrich
a man who was famously unfaithful to two
of his three wives so far trying to get
one to sign divorce documents while she
was recovering from cancer surgery and
asking the second for a divorce shortly
after she was diagnosed with ms no
wonder he just sat there silently until
hannity started speaking again i'm sure
he desperately wanted to get up and walk
out but i guess newt would never do that
to sean he only does that to people with
severe illnesses
but the point is
offsets allow businesses that can't
immediately reduce their emissions to
balance things out by buying emissions
reductions somewhere else and in some
parts of the world they're actually a
way to meet regulatory requirements on
emissions places like china korea
australia and california have set caps
for how much companies can emit and if
you go above that cap you might opt to
buy an offset to get back below it but
companies operating outside of those
areas might still choose to buy offsets
voluntarily so that they can make claims
like the ones that you saw earlier in
those ads the voluntary market is
smaller but it is growing incredibly
fast it's quadrupled to nearly two
billion dollars in 2021. even you as an
individual can now buy offsets you might
have seen checkboxes like these on sites
like ups offering you the opportunity to
offset the carbon of your delivery or
maybe you were offered an offset as an
impulse buy while traveling
travelers through austin's airport can
help offset the emissions their flights
put into the atmosphere it only costs
two dollars and offsets more than one
thousand miles of air travel now that
price is obviously too low it is pretty
suspicious that you could walk into an
airport and offset more than a thousand
miles of air travel for just two dollars
then head over to a chimo express where
it costs at least five times that to buy
a soggy chicken wrap that somehow looks
if i had to pick one descriptor
recently divorced
there are even boutique companies now
popping up like yepu the world's first
human breath carbon offset service where
you can for 17 a year offset your own
breath and if you just let out a huge
exasperated sigh of hearing that bad
news that'll cost you extra
yep you also offers you the chance to
offset your pets ranging from 50 cents
for a hamster to six dollars for a cat
all the way to ten dollars to offset
your pig which again seems great aside
from the fact that ten dollars to offset
your pig sounds like a dutch sex act
that was sent back and forth through
google translate one too many times for
ten dollars basilius he offshed your
pigs show good show strong your eyes
will pop and your brave testicles will
switch shall we doing dish brazilian off
shed that pig
and look on some level you probably know
carbon offsets are [ __ ] both because
you're a reasonably intelligent person
and because you know exactly what show
you are watching right now
i don't open my beak to squawk out good
news
this thing pops open for sad news and
porridge and i'm all out of porridge
right now
but exactly how offsets are [ __ ] is
really interesting because it's easy to
say that you are reducing carbon
emissions but it is much harder to prove
it and the truth is there aren't many
checks and balances in place to prevent
abuse and let's start with the fact that
a key criterion for any offset project
is what's called additionality the idea
is that an offset should provide an
extra reduction of carbon that wouldn't
have happened any other way for instance
if you planted a tree that wouldn't
otherwise have been planted that is
additional as is saving a tree that
would otherwise have been cut down but
there are many many cases where the
claim of additionality is shaky at best
take jp morgan which announced that it
had achieved carbon neutrality across
its operations in 2020 one of the ways
that it claims to have eliminated its
carbon footprint is by buying almost a
million dollars worth of offsets
claiming to protect an area in
pennsylvania called hawk mountain
sanctuary but it turns out that the
threats to the sanctuary were wildly
overblown this is the project's planning
document submitted in 2018 to the
american carbon registry and this is the
baseline the projects built upon that if
it weren't for intervention the forest
would be subject to aggressive clear
cutting and high grading the problem was
hawk mountain preserve as its name would
suggest was already a preserve
since the 1930s this area has been
closely looked after managed and
protected the forest didn't need saving
it wasn't under threat
yeah of course it wasn't and that
probably should have been obvious from
the fact that it was a preserve and not
called the hawk mountain chop chop zone
and tree murder playground
as a reporter from bloomberg uncovered
that offset was sold to jp morgan by the
nature conservancy which has been very
active in selling carbon offset projects
they also sold 180 000 credits to disney
which ostensibly went to protect this
forest in rural pennsylvania from what
the conservancy warned was a risk of
significant commercial timber harvesting
but you should know the nature
conservancy itself had owned most of
that land since 1999 and they are not
famously in the commercial timber
harvesting business and you might think
well i don't care good for them they're
taking disney's money and not having to
give them anything in return but they
are giving them something though namely
they're given the ability to make claims
like disney reduced over 4 million tons
of carbon dioxide equal to taking over
900 000 cars off the road which we
already know is not true but if it were
i'd at least hope that they'd start with
mata i don't care
if he's lightning mcqueen's best friend
he's choking us he's choking our planet
to death
also the money from offsets doesn't
always go to places like the nature
conservancy remember that airport plan
where you could offset more than a
thousand miles of air travel for just
two dollars records show that this year
a significant portion of the money from
that program has gone to support trees
at the hudson farm club in new jersey a
3 800 acre private hunting club set up
by peter kellogg billionaire and model
for the l.l bean heart failure of the
yacht club collection
here is one member explaining what
happens there
peter
had this vision
of having a place for
several of his friends and additional
members to hunt in new jersey and to
shoot new jersey and to develop one of
the best sporting clays spots in the
whole northeast if not the country
it's called hudson farm it's
approximately 3 800 acres it's in
andover new jersey it's one of the most
beautiful places on earth i've ever seen
and it is a hunters and shooters
paradise
okay first it's not just me we're we're
all getting strong get out vibes from
that place right it's not just me
and second the hudson farm club and the
carbon credit company bluesource claimed
that without the money from carpet
offsets 77
of its trees could be clear-cut in just
five years but that clearly wasn't gonna
happen it's owned by a billionaire and
exists for rich guys to fantasize about
shooting animals in the wild right down
to this life-sized carpool cutout of a
buffalo on four wheels
in fact i'd argue the only real damage
that might happen there is from that guy
you saw talking earlier who seems in
real danger of casually shooting off his
own nut sack
and with the market for carbon offsets
increasing there are now companies
actively recruiting almost anyone who
has a tree to get in on the action firms
like these are in the business of
finding small land owners and connecting
them with companies who pay them not to
cut down their trees pitching themselves
with ads like this one from ncx
we're in a critical decade for the
climate and forests are a powerful
natural solution for removing carbon
from the atmosphere ncx's forest data
scientists developed the first high
resolution forest map of every acre of
america now every land owner and every
acre of forest can be part of the
climate solution
right basically they will pay you to
leave your trees alone which is a pretty
good deal as it should be easy not to
cut down trees unless of course we're
talking about this one because honestly
[ __ ] this tree it has at least seven
different eyes teeth and it seems to be
vomiting up a bush you look like the
giving tree if all it gave you was
nightmares and was written by h.b
lovecraft i hate this tree
and with ncx you don't even have to
promise never to cut your trees down as
they give you the option to still get
paid simply to defer cutting them down
for as little as one year but a 12 month
delay doesn't really benefit the planet
much as one expert that we talked to
frankly it's akin to selling a carbon
credit for holding your breath for 15
seconds also there's a much bigger
problem with all of these tree based
programs which is that even if they do
protect one section of trees from
logging that doesn't necessarily mean
much if a logging operation simply cuts
down the trees on the land next door
instead plus given that forest fires are
now on the rise thanks to climate change
offset programs can and have literally
gone up in flames
all of this is why while companies love
to make big broad claims about the
benefits of their offsets they really
don't like getting into the details take
the airline ryanair a few years ago they
began a voluntary program where
customers could contribute one euro to
help offset their flight pointing to
tree planting schemes in ireland and
portugal that would help them do that
but an expert later found those schemes
offset just 0.01
of ryanair's 2019 emissions and when its
ceo was pressed on this he got a little
defensive
the point here is that you've got a
large and growing airline that emits a
lot of carbon dioxide and your
offsetting scheme nowhere near
absolutely meets that but there's an
irish forest
isn't there in ross common yeah which is
seven hectares i mean it is nothing
from little acorns grow mighty trees if
you've only got seven hectares you're
only going to get seven eggs worth of
mighty oak sauce we started this in the
last year i mean we're working with four
projects a re you know we're replanting
trees in
monchique in portugal we're supporting
whales and dogs
which has nothing to do with carbon
dioxide bizarre which has nothing to do
with carbon dioxide but it's good for
the environment yeah i don't think any
of our customers will object to
supporting whales and dolphins in
ireland okay it's not that people would
object to that of course people love
whales and dolphins whales are big
honking boys who up [ __ ] water out of
their heads and dolphins are smooth
friendly water dogs who cackle like
demonic babies they're both excellent
but protecting them isn't the thing that
you promised it's like if you asked your
husband to pick up your kids from school
and he came home childless but with a
pizza you're not mad at the pizza no
one's ever mad at the pizza but it's not
the important thing that he said he was
gonna [ __ ] do
the problem with carbon offsets is
everyone wants to believe in them buyers
want a cheap way to make a big claim and
sellers want money for doing as little
as possible and ideally there'd be an
entity in the middle charged with
keeping both sides honest and there
actually is they're called carbon offset
registries and they are supposed to be
neutral third parties who sign off on
the efficacy of potential offsets these
four are the major ones in the voluntary
offset market but those registries
aren't really accountable to anyone
technically you or i could start a
registry and given that they are paid by
the company selling the offset it will
not surprise you to learn that many
experts say their standards are far too
low as exemplified by the fact the hawke
mountain preserve the disney forest and
the hunting club all met the standards
of the american carp and registry
basically getting a sign off from a
carbon registry is like winning a kid's
choice award it doesn't really mean much
but it will help you temporarily look a
little bit greener
and look the problem isn't those
projects themselves it is good to
protect forests but the issue is
claiming that they cancel out carbon
emissions because truly offsetting
carbon is technically possible
theoretically if a wind farm gets built
to replace a fossil fuel plant that had
zero likelihood of getting built
otherwise that could be a genuine offset
but real world examples of that are
incredibly hard to find one study of
wind turbine projects in india for
instance found that at least 52
of approved carbon offsets were for
projects that would very likely have
been built anyway which causes real
damage because polluters in countries
that cap emissions bought those offsets
and when you buy an offset so you can
pollute more and that offset is [ __ ]
you're now actively making things worse
in fact that study argues the sale of
those offsets substantially increased
global carbon dioxide emissions which
clearly is not very good
and there is one final way that carbon
offsets can cause harm because when that
bp spokesperson with the goth balloons
referred to building an offsetting
project miles away maybe on the other
side of the world
it is worth remembering that people
might be living there a decade ago the
swedish energy agency announced that it
had bought carbon credits from a company
called green resources which said it had
planted pine forests in uganda that
could offset carbon emissions elsewhere
the problem was thousands of rural
ugandans were evicted by the ugandan
government to make room for the
plantation including this man whose
family once farmed a large plot of land
there
when i was seven years old i started
herding cattle the other kids and i
heard the livestock on our land there
were rocks which were remnants from my
great great grandfather's day
do you have a possibility to just show
us where your land was uh-uh no that
would be a problem i can get in trouble
if i show you the land that's obviously
awful no one should ever be scared to
show someone a piece of land unless of
course that [ __ ] janky tree is on it
if there were any squirrels living in
you they have since died of
embarrassment and i hope that you know
that
and the swedish energy agency will point
out that they've now backed away from
that ugandan project but i will point
out that they only did that after that
new segment that you just saw embarrass
them on swedish television and they were
completely fine with it until then so it
seems at best the benefits of carbon
offsets are wildly overstated while the
harm they can do is very real and while
there are ongoing efforts to at least
improve the standards of registries the
truth is offsets aren't the answer here
fundamentally we cannot offset our way
out of climate change even the current
ceo of united airlines knows this he's
one of the few heads of a fossil fuel
dependent company who's actually willing
to acknowledge how inadequate offsets
can be
the real challenge we have
globally is that mankind produces 4 000
times as many emissions as we did in the
pre-industrial era and most of these
carbon offset projects are about
planting trees there's not room on the
planet to plant 4 000 times as many
trees it simply can't be the answer and
the problem with it is is it's the easy
solution it's the solution that if
you're sitting in the c-suite you can
write a check and check the box and have
a marketing message that i've offset all
my car but you really haven't done
anything he's right that airline ceo is
right
although it does speak to the seductive
power of offsets that even his company
can't seem to give them up because if
you go to the united airlines website
right now you will find a page where you
can offset your flight in front of a
picture of a [ __ ] forest
so at least one of those people sitting
in the c-suite happily checking a box is
the ghost of mark zuckerberg future
but it is true that there literally
isn't enough space for every company to
plant trees and fulfill their own net
zero pledge by one estimate there's only
about 500 million hectares of land left
that can be dedicated to new forest for
carp and capture and shell alone has
proposed planting a tenth of that amount
the bottom line is we have an offset
system that places profits over science
and the rules regulating it are just far
too lacks and the reason i know that is
remember when i said five minutes ago
that i could set up a carbon registry
you already knew where this was heading
right
you knew if they had a loophole where i
could set up a registry establish
whatever standards i wanted and start
listing projects that i was going right
through that [ __ ] loophole right you
knew that was gonna happen well i'm glad
to say that you were correct we set up
oliver's offsets carbon registry and i'm
thrilled to announce an exciting new
project that meets our exacting
standards so please come with me
because
as you're about to see
we have trees in our studio now trees
that you can help protect while also
offsetting your personal carbon
footprint now are any of these trees
really under threat i'm certainly going
to tell you that they are because i will
cut down every single one of these
[ __ ] here i'll do it maybe there are
birds living in here or whales
who knows but don't worry you can save
these trees simply by sending me one
dollar we are issuing 10 000 carbon
credits each of which will stop me
cutting this tree down for exactly five
minutes all you have to do is go to
oliversoffsets.org
pay me a dollar and in return we will
send you back a card that you can use as
proof that you are now carbon neutral
we're making big claims while doing very
little which honestly is entirely
reflective of the system that we
currently have so why not offset your
carbon today all proceeds will go to
saving irish whales and dolphins and who
on earth would have a problem with that
anyway that's our show thank you so much
for watching
[Applause]
you